Transcriber: aya fawzy
المدقّق: Mujtaba Abdelwhab
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم .
انا ادعي نجاه الخنجان.
نجاه امدادم الخنجان.
سعيدة جدا .
ان اعتلي هذه المنصة .
واخاطب هذه العقول النيرة .
أنا إخوان الموضوع بتعقيدات بي سي .
دع الأزهار تنمو .
لن يكون مستحيلا.
ولن يكون مستحيلا الآن او في المستقبل.
أن ينمو أبناؤنا أطفالنا
فلذات أكبادنا.
أمام أعيننا
في الاتجاه الصحيح .
في الحقيقه اريد ان ابدا حديثي بقصه.
قديما قيل إن قدماء الصينيين.
فكروا أن
يبنوا سور الصين العظيم.
المشهور في الاساطير.
كما تعرفون جميعا.
ارادوا بناء هذا السور
كي لا يغزوهم العدو في بلدهم.
وبالفعل بنوا سور الصين العظيم.
ولكن في المائة سنة الأولى
تم قصفهم ثلاث مرات .
كان الأعداء
لا يكسروا السور او يتسلقوه
لكن كانوا يدخلون الباب
لأنهم كانوا يرشون الحارس .
لأن الصينيون انشغلوا في بناء السور العظيم
ونسوا أنهم يبنوا الحارس
فبناء الانسان قبل كل شيء
وهذا ما نصبو إليه .
هناك ارقام مهولة في العالم
عن الأطفال وعن أوضاعهم .
هل تعلم أن هناك ثلاثمئة مليون طفل
مستقلون في النزاعات المسلحة ؟
وان هناك مائتين وخمسين طفل يعملون
منهم مائة وثمانين
مليون طفل يعملون في أعمال شاقة ؟
وهل تعلمون أن أربعين مليون طفل
يعيشون مسلوبي الحرية
لمخالفتهم للقانون ؟
وهل تعلم ان
مائة مليون طفل يتم الاتجار بهم سنويا ؟
ومليون طفل يعيشون حياة قاسية .
إهمال والتمييز.
، وما بين مائة إلى مائة
وثلاثين مليون فتاة في أفريقيا
تم بتر و تشويه
الأعضاء التناسلية الأنثويه لهن.
لكم أن تتخيلوا هذا العنف .
حقيقة .
هذه الأرقام أنا متأكد أنها لمست حاجة من
دواخلكم
ولمست بلدانكم لأننا نحن إخواننا
في أسر يعني وغد واحد من الأسر يطلع منها
طفل مشرد
أو يطلع منها طفل فاقد رعاية والديه
أو هيطلع منها طفل في تماس مع
القانون
أو طفل جانح أو معرض للجنوح .
لماذا الاهتمام بالأطفال ؟
ومن هو الذي يربي الأطفال ؟
كلكم لخانة التبغ معين
الأسرة هي التي تنشئ الأطفال ،
فالأسرة
هي المسؤول الأول عن رعاية الأطفال
في مرحلة من مراحل الطفل تتكون شخصيته
ووجدانه وميوله
والأسرة أيضا لها دور كبير
جدا في إنها يخرج منها من يقود المجتمع ومن
يقود العالم
فالأسرة اخوانا لها دور كبير جدا جدا
ومن هي الأسرة التي يمكن أن تنجح
في ان تربي لنا الأطفال؟
هي الأسرة المتعلمة الواعية المثقفة
التي تقوم بدورها خير قيام
أحد المستشرقين قال إذا اردت ان تهدم أمة
فعليك بسلاسة هدم الأسرة
هدم التعليم ، إسقاط القدوات والمرجعيات .
لهدم الأسرة عليك بالأم
غيب دورها واجعلها
تخجل من أن تكون ربة منزل .
لهدم التعليم عليك بالمعلم
لا تحترمه ولا تقدره
واجعل طلابه لا يحترمونه .
وإذا أردت أن تقتل القدوات والمرجعيات
عليك بالعلماء أطعن فيهم .
إذا غابت الأم الصالحة .
قطعا الأسرة تكون ما هي البتر البلينا ،
وإذا غاب المعلم فعلا التعليم إنهدم
ونحن نقول قم للمعلم وفف التبجيلا
كاد المعلم أن يكون رسولا .
وإذا سقطت القدوات والمرجعيات
فمن يربي النشء على القيم؟
أنا عندي سؤال هنا أخواننا .
إذا يعني الأسر
طبعا في عادات وتقاليد
موروثات جميلة
يمكن أن نقتدي بها منذ زمن بعيد
ولكنني اسالكم هنا
هل اذا تمسكت الاسر
بالعادات والتقاليد والموروثات
المتسمه بالاسائه للاطفال
وبالاهمال وبالتمييز
هل تستحق تلك الاسره ان تربي طفلا؟
قطعا لا
إخواني نحن لدينا عادات وتقاليد أضرت في
أطفالنا ضررا جسيما
وهذا يعد احد التحديات الحثيه
ان الاسر لا تستطيع معالجه مشاكل ابنائها
إن الطفل، ونحن لا نتكلم عن فردا واحدا
بل فئه عمريه محدده
لقد تحدثت الاتفاقيات الدولية
والمعاهدات والمواثيق
عن من هو الطفل ؟
كل من لم يبلغ الثامنة عشر فهو طفلا .
حتى السودان واحد من الدول التي وقعت صادقت
على هذه الاتفاقيات
، فبالتالي أنا أتحدث
عن الفئة العمرية دون سن الثمانية عشر
يا اخوتي ان الطفل يريد حبا وحنانا
منذ الصغر وحتي الكبر
يريد ان ينتبه اليه الوالدان حين يتحدث
والا يتجاهلا كلامه
فذالك التجاهل يؤثر فيهم.
فمن احدي العادات عند التجمعات العائليه
فحين يبدي طفل رايه في مجلس الكبار يتم نهره
واخباره بالذهاب للعب مع الاطفال
قد يكون رايه يا اخواني اصوب من راي الكبار
ويؤدي ذلك الي جعل الطفل انهزاميا وانطوائيا
وقد يجعله يلجا الي الغرباء
ليجد من يستمع له
هناك اعتقاد عند الام
انه اذا خرج ابنها للشارع
فقد يصادف شخصا سيئا
وتلقى أقران سيئين سواء كان في الشارع أو
في المدرسة ، فلابد أن يكون هناك متابعة
لصيقة من الأم والأب والأسرة
اخواني نحن نربي جيلا واعيا بليغا
مليء بالمعرفة والإدراك
، فإذا لم نعاملهم معامله جيده منذ الصغر
قد لا يقبل كلامك حين الكبر
فحينئذ يكون قد فات الاوان
لكن ان كان متعلقا بك منذ الصغر
فقد يقبل كلامك حين الكبر
التحديات الكبيرة جدا .
أخواننا ثورة المعلومات والتكنولوجيا .
العولمة .
العولمه يا اخواني
لها سلبياتها كما لها ايجابياتها
كلنا في هذه القاعه
نحمل هواتف ذكيه. شاشات ذكيه.
تعرض لنا العالم بكل تقنياته وتعقيداته
وثقافاته .
لكننا لا نعرف اثر
امتلاك الاطفال لتلك الشاشات
علينا نحن الأمهات والآباء .
علينا أن نمنع تمعن الاطفال في تلك الشاشات
لأن هناك فجوة كبيرة جدا اخواني
علماء المجتمع قالوا يوجد فجوة معرفية كبيرة
جدا عبر الفواصل الاجتماعية المختلفة .
فجوة في العمر .
فاصل في العمر وفي النوع وفي السكن
وفي المستوى المعيشي والمستوى التعليمي .
سواء كنت في الريف او في المدينه
صغار المدن أو كبار المدن لأن نعمق بوقتنا
لا بعلمك الله قاعد في كسلا ولا داعي في
الميالة الأذاعة كفرتم مثل الشلك .
معلومات ممكن تقلب رأسك تقلب
حياتك رأسا على عقب .
ليه أخواننا لأن أنا للصفر مع نضيفة .
الطفل يقول ان الطفل ينضج بعد الثامنه عشر
ينضج عاطفيا وعقليا ويصبح مسئولا
فبالتالي اخوتي يجب ان تعي الاسر تماما
دور التعليم
فالمراه اذا كانت متعلمه
يمكنها ان تقود امه
ويعد احد من العادات والتقاليد والموروثات
زواج الطفلات
أو الزواج المبكر أو زواج القاصرات
لأن إخواننا البيت الغير متعلمة
تنقطع عن رفيقاتها وعن العلم
ولا يمكنها ان تقود اسره
ويمكن في مشاكل كثيرة جدا جدا .
حاصلة في مجتمعنا
ويعد احد التحديات
هو الأطفال أو التفكك الأسري .
الطفل أخواننا لمن أم أبوه يختلفوا
عارفيه
حاجة ذوي الحاجات كلها تمشي أزياء أكل وشرب
ويدرس ، وكل حاجة تكون موجودة .
لكن عندما يخرج الاب او الام من البيت
فما حال حال هذا الطفل ؟
يلجا للشارع ويصبج متشرد ويدخل السجن
وذلك حسب الاحصائات المتاحه امامنا
ويوجد عنف شديد جدا تجاه الاطفال
وهذا يعد احد القضايا المثارة حديثا ونسبيا
بأن هناك عنف في الأسرة
وعنف في المدرسة ، وعنف في الشارع .
ونتيجه لهذا العنف
يمكن للطفل ان يفقد نفسه
ويفقد أهله بحثا عن الأحسن
لما يلجا لذلك؟
لانه يري اطفالا اخرين في وضع افضل
يعيشون مع اهلهم في حب وحنان وتماسك
قد يذهب للبحث عن اسره اخري
لان الانسان يا اخوتي دائما يبحث عن الافضل
من المعالجة هذه المشاكل لابد من أن الأسر
تعي دورها
بالتعليم وبرفع الوعي
مسؤولة إخواننا في جهات مسؤولة
عن أنه كيف
هذا الطيف ينمو ويترعرع وإلى أن يصبح إنسان
كبير يستفاد منه وهذا لن يحدث الا عبر
جلسات الحوار والنقاش حول أوضاع الأطفال
وحول أوضاع الأسر ومعالجة المشاكل ،
ويمكن
واحد من مشاكل كبيرة جدا الذي هو الفقر
والظروف الاقتصادية الطاحنة ،
هي ممكن تعصف بأسرة كانت متماسكة
بأسرة كانت مع بعضها في حب ووئام
ويعد احد المشاكل هو الرجل أو الأب .
العنف الممارس من الآباء اتجاه الأبناء
لانه يريد ان يخرج مع اصدقائه
بالضافه الي عده رغبات
ولكن رد فعل  الاب تجاه تلك الرغبات
يكون عنيف جدا
مما يلجا الطفل للبحث عن والد اخر
إخوان .
أنا والله في ختام حديثي أمامي شابات وشباب
ونحن نعول على الشباب كثير جدا
باطلاعه وفهمه ومعرفته
كل فتاة وكل شاب يمكن
ان يكون رسولا في أسرته وممكن يحمي أخوانه
الصغار ويحمي أبناءه .
أسرة شكرا جزيلا .